hi
my name is daniel mitchelski and welcome
to the itcs talk on total functions in
the polynomial hierarchy
uh this is joint work with my advisor
christos papilimitrio
at columbia bobby kleinberg at cornell
and oliver corton at columbia
so here is an overview of our work at a
very high level
this talk is about function problems not
decision problems
and very occasionally we might use a
decision complexity class when we mean a
function class
i'll point that out if that happens so
specifically we're interested for
instance in
fnp and not decisional np
uh what is fnp as a quick reminder
you know the complete problem for fnp is
the
sat search problem it is
given a satisfiable formula find
a satisfying assignment this can of
course be verified with a polynomial
time machine
uh of course in this relation uh not
every formula participates in the
relation not all of them
are satisfiable so this leads to the
definition of tfnp
or total fmp these are problems f in f
and p
that are total every instance has a
solution
but we'll define this more rigorously in
a second
and recall from your introduction to
complexity
course that np generalizes to a
polynomial hierarchy
of sigma i and pi i complexity classes
so in our work we essentially generalize
tfnp
to an analogous hierarchy of classes
which we call
tf sigma-i and we identify natural
problems in these classes
as one does in tfnp research and
corresponding subclasses
in this hierarchy so without further ado
let's begin so
let's define tfnp a relation
rxy is total if for every x there is a y
such that x
y is in the relation in other words for
every input there is some
solution or some y in the relation
and tf and p can be defined as those
relations in f and p
which are total but here is a more
technical definition
which if you'd like you can stop and
look at a relation is in tf and p if
it's polynomial
so the um
the y's are polynomial there's a fixed
polynomial in the length at in the
length of x
uh the relation is total and
there exists a polynomial time machine
such that x y is in the relation
if the machine accepts x y
great so a little bit about tfnp
probably tfmp has no complete problems
unlike fnp which as we've discussed has
the complete problem of
search sat but tfnp does have a variety
of interesting problems
where a solution is guaranteed in other
words the problem is total
this has to be the case for it to be in
tfnp but we do not know how to compute
this solution in polynomial time
so some sort of argument some sort of
non-constructive argument guarantees
that a solution exists for every x
and then evidence for intractability of
a specific search problem
can be obtained by showing completeness
of that search problem for one of these
subclasses in tfnp
so these subclasses are defined by
reduction to some problem and what
what they're really defined by is that
they're grouping problems in tfnp
by a shared combinatorial principle
which is used in the proof of totality
right the same principle guarantees
existence of a solution
and this underlies the definition of all
of the uh tfnp subclasses that you may
have seen before ppp
ppa pls and so on
um so let me tell you about one of these
classes in particular and the very
simple combinatorial argument
which gives rise to it uh this example
is the class ppp
so consider the following uh simple
argument
given a mapping which has fewer outputs
than it has inputs
there has to be a collision in the
output space and this is guaranteed by
the set theoretic pigeonhole principle
so let's translate this to a concrete
computational problem
we define the pigeonhole search problem
given a circuit
which maps n-bit strings 10-bit strings
either find an x that is the pre-image
of the zero string
or find the collision and
this problem is total a solution is
guaranteed to exist because if there is
no pre-image of zero
the output space is smaller than the
input space so there must be a collision
by the pigeonhole principle
this is a very simple problem to define
but of course the solution is guaranteed
by this
set theoretic argument and it's unclear
how looking
at a circuit which implicitly represents
this mapping
how to find this collision or a preimage
of zero for that matter
so we defined the class ppp which stands
for polynomial pigeonhole principle
uh the first p doesn't stand for
papademy trio contrary to popular belief
as those relations in tf and p which are
polynomial time reducible
to the pigeonhole problem
but now consider this uh simple
combinatorial argument
the empty pigeonhole principle this time
given a mapping with more outputs than
inputs
by the same logic there exists an empty
pigeonhole
there exists some output which isn't
mapped to by any input
and so analogously we can define a
computational problem
the empty problem this time we're given
the circuit mapping two to the n
minus one inputs to two to the n outputs
concretely we can simply remove uh the
zero string as a possible input
all right it's just not it's not um
considered
and the goal is to find a y such that
there is no x
that maps to y under this circuit now at
very first glance this seems somewhat
similar to the pigeonhole problem and
one can ask is it in ppp
is it ppp complete but when you think
about it um
even briefly you'll see no this is
somehow different
because checking a solution requires
looking at
all the pigeons in the input space
so there seems to be some sort of
quantifier at play you have to look at
all possible inputs to check that uh the
that y as an empty pigeonhole
so this leads to the definition of tf 2.
all right t of sigma 2 can be thought of
as total problems
in functional sigma 2. but here's a
concrete definition
a relation r x y and t of sigma 2 if
it's a polynomial relation if it is
total
and this time there exists a verifying
machine m and polynomial p
such that x y is in the relation if for
all z of this polynomial length
m x y z accepts so in other words the
sigma 2 machine accepts
and analogously we can define an entire
hierarchy of
total search classes
the t of sigma i which are
total relations in a functional sigma i
and if you want you can take a look take
a second to pause and look at these
definitions
but they are they correspond to um
you know definitions of this of the
polynomial hierarchy in decisional
problems
great so now let's look let's get back
to this empty problem we were talking
about
so i'll remind you briefly of the
technical definition of mt we're given a
circuit mapping
2 to the n minus 1 inputs to 2 to the n
outputs and we have to find a y such
that no x
maps to y now we can say that mt is ntf
sigma 2.
the verifying machine quantifies over
all possible x
and verifies that none of them mapped to
y
and i'll take a moment at this point to
say and the details are spelled out in
our paper
that the tf sigma i the total hierarchy
behaves in ways you might expect
you can essentially define the t of
sigma i as
tf and p with a sigma i minus one oracle
similarly to how you can define sigma i
through oracles
and this i remember this now because
you know one could just one could define
m as a polynomial machine with a sigma i
oracle
um and it checks that no x maps to y
and similarly to how we define
subclasses in tfnp
based off a problem which is total by
some natural
non-constructive argument we define the
class p-e-p-p
which stands for polynomial mt
pigeonhole principle
as all the total relations in tfnp
um sorry all total relations which are
polytime reducible to the empty problem
so pepp is some subclass of tf sigma 2.
and this is a bit informal but one
should think about pepp as search
problems
where the solutions are guaranteed by
the union bound
or the empty pigeonhole principle but
the union bound is another way to think
about that
um in the union bound we are given a
bunch of sets and we know the size of
these sets
and we know that the sum of the sizes of
these sets is less than some
output space so there must be an element
in the output space which isn't in any
of the input spaces
and if you translate this to some
circuit search problem
you end up with the empty definition
essentially so
we will see this union bound argument
reappear
and incidentally and this is interesting
fnp is in pepp
um now let me explain this for a second
because this might be a bit confusing
fnp isn't even the problems in fnp
aren't total
what we described at the beginning the
search version of sat there are many x
which don't participate in this relation
namely all x which are not satisfiable
formulae
but you can extend such a relation to
one
where for the non-satisfiable formulas
you
insert into the relation that formula
with an
output such as the word unsatisfiable
now of course that can't be verified by
an np machine but it turns out that that
relation isn't is in ppp
so that's what's meant by this and the
proof is easy but it's interesting
because
this somehow um says something different
about pepp from tfnp for instance
great now now i will present to you
several problems that we identified
which are very natural and live
in uh tf sigma 2 and in fact live in
pepp
and i've sort of chosen the most
interesting ones
so this is the remote point problem
we're given a circuit which represents a
code which goes from embed strings to n
bit strings okay and n is going to be
larger than m
and we're also given a d such that
when you take all the code words
produced by c
and you take hamming balls of size d
around all of those code words you don't
cover the entire output space
and by the union bound there must be a
bit string in the output space
which is neither a code word nor in a d
hamming ball around
any code word so find a bit string which
is
hamming distance d far from any code
word
so this is an interesting problem um and
it relates to coding theory
and at first we asked ourselves although
this was
pepp complete and we thought maybe this
would be an interesting problem but
based on how it's defined it's actually
trivially p e p d complete
you simply take d equals zero and then
you're looking for
um you're looking for a bit string which
is different from any
input uh but of course the problem
remains for
large d sorry this should say what about
for large d
and it also is interesting to ask
whether this problem is complete or
whatever its properties a c must be a
linear code
or some other restriction on on c other
than being an arbitrary circuit
now the next natural problem is matrix
rigidity
so matrix rigidity
um we say that a matrix an n by n matrix
m
over a field f is delta rigid
if it is quite far from having low rank
in a certain
sense it's delta rigid if you can't
modify m to have rank
less than delta times n which is much
less than n
by only modifying n to the delta entries
in every row of this matrix you know
clearly if you replace all the entries
in the matrix with zero it would have
zero rank but it can't be done by only
replacing
n to the delta entries in each row
um this the existence of
delta rigid matrices um is guaranteed
also by a very simple union bound like
argument
uh there exists one for every n by n
matrix but there even exists one
for every matrix where you filled in
several of the first rows with some
values
so this leads to the definition of a
very natural search problem the delta
rigid matrix completion problem
given the first log n rows of an n by a
matrix
over some fixed field but let's take f2
as a simple example
find a delta rigid completion of this
matrix by filling in the remain
remaining n minus log n rows
so as i just explained to you and you
can look at the details in the paper
this is a total problem
again the union bound guarantees
the existence of these completions and
you may ask why are we providing
uh the first log n rows as an input you
could you could defend this problem
without that and say simply find a delta
origin matrix
of size n by n but then this becomes a
unary
search problem um and this is more
general in fact right we're saying for
it's a total problem for any
input to the first log n rows we can
find a delta completion of that matrix
so you can think about this and you'll
see very quickly that it is in tf sigma
2
because the verifying machine can simply
try all modifications to this matrix
in each row you can make at most n to
the power of delta of them
so we simply try n choose n to the delta
modifications in each row and
that can be quantified over with a
polynomial string
and in fact a very simple union down
like argument
shows that this problem isn't ppp and
you can look at the details
and so here's the next very natural
problem the third one
and it has to do with uh in a sense this
problem is related to one of the
fundamental goals in complexity theory
which is to find a boolean function and
variables which requires superpolynomial
circuits
in an early proof by shannon which also
uses a union bound like argument
we know that almost all boolean
functions need large circuits they need
circuits larger than 2
to the power of some constant times n
divided by log n size circuits
and of course we don't know any such
explicit simple natural function
and this is one of the fundamental goals
of complexity theory to separate say
uh p poly from p even
um so we are going to come up with a
corresponding search problem
so given the bit string x of length m
this is important
we're going to think of x as encoding a
function on log
m bits
and then we can define an x oracle
circuit
as simply a circuit which contains gates
which uh
compute this function x okay the
function x indicated by the string x
um and this gate of course has log m fan
n if
x was a string of length m okay we need
this definition in order to be able to
have an input into this search problem
similarly to how we had an input to the
rigid matrix completion problem by
providing the first login rows
so we defined complexity as the
following search problem we're given an
x of length n which represents a
function on log n bit log n bits
and the goal is to find another function
on log n
inputs which is not computed by any x
oracle circuit which uses less than a co
some fixed constant times n over log
squared and gates
all right and the existence of such
functions in fact many is guaranteed by
the
by the simple union bound proof of
shannon um
and the log squared n in the denominator
there is a technical artifact which
comes from the fact that you need login
bits
to um to write down the x-oracle circuit
gates
sorry the ex-oracle gates the details
are in the paper
and again we have that complexity is in
ppp
um because one can one can sort of
construct this artificial circuit
which computes all functions um all
circuits of
of the size and then check that none of
them compute
the function the candidate function
so this this problem is also in ppp
now there's something interesting about
these about the previous problems i
mentioned
they actually involve a mapping from
n-bit strings to m-bit strings
where m is larger than n and this is
different from the p-e-p-p
problem in which there were there simply
had to be one more
output than input here we're often
doubling the output space compared to
the input space
so this leads to the following
definition alpha pp
are those total functions which are
reducible to
alpha empty okay which is the search
problem
uh where given the circuit mapping two
to the n inputs
to one plus alpha times two to the m
outputs
find any empty pigeon hole in fact there
are many much more than one as in ppp
and for simplicity and convenience we
define we define apppp to be
one pepp in other words
in other words empty pigeonhole
search where the output space is at
least twice as big as the input space
and so we have that these two previous
natural problems delta rigid matrix
completion and complexity are in
apppp so the one of the most interesting
open problems we pose in our paper
is whether complexity and or delta rigid
matrix completion are a p e p p
complete now sort of as a first step it
would be interesting to see whether
they're complete even under np
reductions and this is interesting
because
this is a result that's in our paper i
don't mention it here
under np reductions most interesting
alpha pp are equal to each other if you
take any non-negligible
alpha alpha which is greater than one
over a polynomial
such alpha pp classes reduced to each
other under np reductions
so another result we show in our paper
essentially says that the class apppp
might be quite different than
p-e-p-p in which there's just one more
output than input
because a-p-p-p might be closer to
functional np than
uh that may appear at first
because for non-negligible alpha the
class
alphappp is in
functional p with an np oracle with
polynomial advice
okay actually the proof for this is very
straightforward and there's an
application of you guessed it the union
bound
um and the proof says something slightly
stronger it says that
uh alpha ppp is a subset of functional
zpp zero error uh
probabilistic polynomial time uh with an
np oracle
um but in other words it's it's close
to in some sense to fnp uh it's an fnp
with polynomial advice
and we don't see why for instance ppp
would be in
functional np with polynomial advice
now i'm going to answer a very frequent
question that comes up when i talk to
people about this
many people hear this and they start
thinking about problems that might be
in tf sigma 2 or in ppp and they say
what about this problem what about
optimization
given the circuit from n-bit strings to
mbit strings
find a max input an x such that c
x is greater than all other c x prime
now this problem is in tf sigma 2. of
course it is
but it's actually already understood in
some sense it's complete for uh
fp with an np oracle which is also known
as delta ii
um and it's simple to figure this out
you can use an np oracle to just do
binary search
for this optimum and this has been
understood since the 80s and it's in
krentel's thesis from 1984.
great now what about higher in the
hierarchy let's consider t of sigma 3.
so let's briefly recall t sigma 3 are
those total relations
where x y's in the relation if for all a
exists b such that m accepts
are there natural problems at this level
of the hierarchy and the answer is yes
and i will present two of them to you uh
one of them is
shattering in which large shattered sets
are guaranteed by the sour shallow lemma
and kings a search problem on
tournaments
a kind of diagraph where a solution is
guaranteed by a simple graph theory
argument
so let's take a look so
i'll go over this quickly but you can
you can pause and take a look at these
definitions
more carefully if you'd like to review
them
shattering which is a one of the most
important definitions in classical
learning theory and in vc
learning theory um we say that a family
of sets
f where the sets are over the same
universe usually the numbers one through
n
shatter some set s if you can realize
any subset t
of s or by realize i mean there's some s
i in the family that the subset t of s
can be realized by taking s intersect
with
s i from that family um
a classic learning theory or set
theoretic result
the sarah shala llama comes in two
flavors the strong version says that a
family of sets f
shatters at least cardinality of f sets
over the same universe as the sets s i
and the weak form which is more
frequently encountered basically says
that there is a lower bound
on the size of a set shattered by the
family f
all right there's a set s that's just
shattered by f who's
whose size is at least d and we can
compute this d
so this of course suggests a very
natural search problem find
uh a shattered set s with this with size
d
and when you think about how you verify
shattering uh
you will see that there that there's an
alternation of quantifiers at play and
this will place it in tf sigma 3.
so let's rigorously define the shadowing
problem we're given
a circuit which implicitly represents a
family of sets
all right it maps k bit strings to n bit
strings
so in other words it represents a family
of two to the k different sets
um in
of numbers one through n and we're given
d
such that by the sauro lemma we're
guaranteed the existence of a shattered
set of size at least d
and so the search problem is to either
find
a x1 and x2
two indices such that we get the same
set
which means that we don't actually have
two to the k distinct sets in the family
f
so the conditions for the saracelo
aren't satisfied
or find a shattered set s
of size at least d
so
when you think about how you verify a
possible shattered set s
you need two quantifiers you check that
for every subset t of s
there exists an x i in the family or an
index i such that c of i
that set realizes the subset t and so
this place is shattering in t of sigma
three and the third level of our total
hierarchy
but when you think about this problem
why are we getting a large
um a large shattered set
well the reason is the strong uh sour
shallow lemon which says that this
family of sets shatters at least
cardinality of f
sets so in a sense there are too many
shattered sets so one of them has to be
large because there's so many of them
they can't all be small
so this smells like ppp uh
polynomial pigeonhole principle which
lives in tfnp
because it smells like collision finding
and in fact we
prove in our paper that shattering lives
in oracleized ppp
ppp with a sigma 2 oracle which is a
natural subclass of tf sigma 3.
so very briefly this sort of suggests a
line of research where
we take problems in t of sigma i and
we place them in natural subclasses
of tf sigma-j for a smaller j but with
oracles
so we sort of find structure between
levels of the hierarchy
with oracleized versions of these of
these subclasses
so specifically ppp with an o
oracle this is what it means it's
defined as
ppp but where the input circuit instance
for which we have to find a collision
that input circuit
uh can use an o oracle it has oracle
gates
so shattering lives in ppp with sigma 2
oracle gates so in other words you can
reduce shattering to
to finding a collision of a polynomial
size circuit
where the circuit makes sigma-2 oracle
calls
and the idea is to construct a mapping
an explicit mapping in fact which uses
sigma 2 oracle calls
from f to shattered sets and then with a
simple modification you sort of you make
large sets collide and then you're
looking for a collision to find a large
set
and this is a technical
result in our paper which you can look
at if you're interested and
in the remaining few minutes i'm going
to present you with another natural
problem that we found in the
in tf sigma 3 the king's problem so a
tournament
is a diagraph in which exactly
one of the following two edges is in the
graph either uv
or vu so you can think of this as
a graph representing a tournament let's
say a rock paper scissors
tournament where everyone has played
with everyone okay
now a king in a diagraph is a vertex
which
beats in air quotes every other vertex
where by beats we mean either it
directly beat that vertex
so either k beat you directly the edge k
u is in the graph or it transitively
beats you
it beats a w which beats you
so for every vertex you would either be
you or it beats a w which beats that u
now a very simple graph theory argument
um tells us that every tournament
has a king and i'll give you the
beginning of this argument and you can
complete it
um take the tournament and take a vertex
which has beat or transitively beat the
most vertices
a max all right and consider this vertex
it in fact has to be a king because if
it's not a king
that means there's some vertex it either
doesn't beat it
both it neither beats nor transitively
beats
but if you think about that other vertex
you'll find that it actually will have
it will beat or transitively beat more
vertices than the one you started with
this is a simple argument an exercise
for you to complete
so this uh suggest and it's a
non-constructive argument in a sense you
know given an axe
um there if it's not a max there exists
uh some something it doesn't beat which
transitively beats more than it
in a sense it doesn't tell you how to
find the king
um so this leads the definition of a
search problem kings
so given the circuit which implicitly
represents a tournament
um find a king in this tournament
and this problem lies in tf sigma 3
because the king can be verified by
checking that for all other vertices in
this graph
in this exponentially sized graph uh
either the king beats this vertex
or this is where the second quantifier
comes in there exists
a w such that the king beats w and then
w beats the vertex in question and at
first glance
you know similarly to how when we
thought about shattering we it smelled
like ppp and collision finding
this problem seems like an optimization
problem each vertex in this diagraph has
a potential or a weight
which is the number of vertices it beats
or transitively beats
and so this seems like it should live in
the
in an oraclized version of a specific
tfnp
subclass called pls and roughly speaking
verbally pls
are those problems which um amount to
finding a local uh optimum in a graph
um so maybe we would we would suspect
that maybe this problem lives in pls
with a sigma 2 oracle
but the problem is that when you think
about how you can how you compute this
potential
what circuit would compute the potential
of each vertex
you actually need to count how many
vertices it beats or transitively beats
in the graph
so the oracle would have to be have to
allow you to count this it would have to
be
sharp p so it doesn't seem likely that
kings lives in pls with a sigma 2 oracle
now the last two slides are a conclusion
i'll try to sort of summarize everything
i've told you about
um in short we have introduced a
total polynomial hierarchy and
identified natural problems and
subclasses in this hierarchy
so tf sigma 2 which is total problems in
functional
sigma 2 contained the natural empty
problem
finding a
target in the output space to which no
input maps which leads us to defining
ppp
and then we identified other natural
problems such as rigid matrix completion
and complexity
for which the output space is actually
being doubled we're looking for an empty
output
in an output space that at least doubles
the input space which leads us to
defining alpha ppp
and in particular apppp
and then we also consider natural
problems in tf sigma-3
we find shattering which has to do with
finding large shattered sets
and we find that this actually lives in
an oraclized version of ppp
and we also have the graph theoretic
kings problem okay
great and i'll briefly tell you about
the open problems that we pose on our
paper and future work
so one interesting question we have is
are there other subclasses of tf sigma-2
we know many natural subclasses of tf mp
and which we do not think reduce to one
another yeah
so why is there such a dearth in tf
sigma two
um and this might have the answer to
this question might have connections to
logic
um because there are in logic one
studies
uh sort of generic characterizations of
of the um arguments that lead to
subclasses in tfnp
so there might there are similar generic
arguments perhaps for
for subclasses and t of sigma 2.
um i've already presented this problem
but one might ask whether complexity and
alpha rigid matrix completion
are apppp complete are they complete
even with p to the np reductions
as a starting point uh remote point was
another one is this one a p p p
complete for large d uh what about if
you restrict this problem to only
considering linear codes
another big question is the
classification of kings so we actually
have some recent
results after the after we published
this
we actually identified a second natural
subclass of tf sigma 2 which we call ppm
for
polynomial post-set maximization which
has to do with finding maximal elements
in an implicit in an implicit postset
represented by a circuit and a post a
finite post that might have many maximal
elements
and this turns out to not be the same
thing as as optimization
which i presented in that faq slide
earlier so we don't think right now that
ppm is the same thing as ppp so this
might be a second
natural subclass of tf sigma 2. and we
find
the reason we define this is because
kings lives in ppm with an np
oracle so this um
simply sort of exhibits some structural
connection between
the second and third levels of the of
the total hierarchy
and one can consider other try to look
for other natural problems
in other tf sigma-i perhaps at higher
levels of the hierarchy
and consider and there are many
structural questions that we also pose
on the paper
that have to do with collapse of this
hierarchy
and other connections between these
classes um
i should mention this isn't in the slide
but you know
there are many cryptographic questions
that could be asked about these
questions can we
can we connect hardness assumptions on
these subclasses
or tf sigma-2 uh to
crypto primitives uh or such things
so i hope uh this was interesting um
and if you'd like to learn more please
take a look at our paper and please get
in touch with us
if you have any thoughts uh thank you